crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though Orion's egg the
soccer star jus go above-ground cool
goes better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosed go download this week
last week here we go again for the crab
feast
I yeah
I welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday no crappy for that a
that was nice that was nice as velvet
smooth Jay Larson the fella good enough
it felt like nothing was even coming out
of my mouth I like the sound was just
existing that's what happens when you
touch it right I like to say trick or
treat happy halloween doll you crab
feast is out there have a safe Halloween
this weekend cuz uh you know get
dangerous out there definitely a
dangerous on a hobbit for sure and if
you're young and you don't know this
grab a can of barbasol you stick a pin
in it and then you melt it around at
this I can shoot your shaving cream just
a little note for you didn't you shoot
shaving cream as a kid not like that we
just took it out and shot it till it one
out sprayed it yeah I know but how'd you
get it to spray just put the spray
button on it you said to get right up on
top of somebody's shoe from dis no we
weren't getting take the barber so you
put a pin it then you take a lighter and
you melt the plastic so it melts enter
on the pin when it hardens up you pull
it out now it's just a tiny little hole
you hit it okay ha nothing else for
halloween have a happy halloween make
sure if you go to a door sickle cells
and sitting addresses a scarecrow waco
will be doing that just sick of saying
Ryan Sickler on Twitter and Instagram
Ryan Sickler official on facebook Ryan
Sickler calm st. Louis i'll be there
friday november six that the blueberry
hill one night only doors open at eight
shows at nine you can get tickets there
ten bucks there 12 day of 10 in advance
you go to Ryan Sickler calm the crab
feast calm or Mountain City calm to get
your tickets and bring some people I
want to see st. Louis Feaster's december
twenty sixth and seventh i'm at the brea
improv again stay tuned for special
deals on tickets i'm going to see what
we can do about keeping it really cheap
so if you're in Southern California you
have family and friends in town or
you're just looking for something to do
the day after Christmas come on out I
plan on making it a friends at the crab
feast show we're gonna have a lot of fun
didn't you say you were gonna like
people could bring in a gift that they
didn't like and you'd you'd redo the
gift or something like that we give it
around should have everyone bring
it'll be a whole show and do a white
Christmas we could bring a shitty gift
and do a toy drive or a day after
donation you guys want to I'll talk to
the club about that crab feast calm
excuse me the crab feast calm for all
your crab feast info and this is the
last month of October breast cancer
awareness who has a week of October once
again we are donating a portion of our
merchandise sales to breastcancer.org
breastcancer.org is a non-profit
organization dedicated to providing the
most reliable complete and up-to-date
information about breast cancer it has
over 10 million visitors globally an
active community over 75,000 people
communicating at any given time if you
or someone you know is looking for
support from others going through the
same thing tell him about breast cancer
org the community last month they
launched breast health org with the
golden forum empower and inspire women
and girls protect their breast health
you can follow breast health org on
Twitter and Instagram at go breast
healthy you can also use the hashtag go
breast healthy and just thank you in
advance for all you guys do for us for
helping us with this and for breast
cancer I mean I love that we're able to
do a little little tiny something and
without you guys we wouldn't be able to
do it you guys help us not just with the
breast cancer promotion for the month
but also with everything that we do is
yeah I mean thank you for what you do
with it whether it's amazon or the
premium apps which are only a buck 99
they're available in iTunes and for
androids and non itunes users you help
us keep the the weekly show free so
thank you for doing that likely it's the
last month is the last month of October
right now yeah with the time go man
thank you for following us on Facebook
and lighten the iTunes page up with your
five-star reviews make sure you follow
all things comedy on social media and
again again I don't you guys know couple
one we're working hard to make it so
it's not just a Facebook page with
Facebook official I mean right right got
it dialed we're trying to dial no we
want to mention again we're working on a
project and we can't do anything without
you guys so we'd love for you guys to be
a part
of it and what we're asking you to do is
email us if you're interested we know
you have stories because you've hit us
up and told us and that's why your crab
feast that's why your Feaster's while
you're because you love hearing the
stories and we know you got stories if
you're interested in being part of this
project we're working on email us a
one-minute video tell us your name a
little bit about yourself and then tell
us a little bit about your story we just
like if you got a great story everyone's
got at least one great story you know
whatever it is you know what we're all
about yeah if you if you have a great
story if you think you're a great
storyteller and you tell that story
great then show us by emailing us at
crab feast podcast at gmail com like
jason said state your name tell us where
you live keep a little about yourself in
it and boom your story keep it to around
a minute you know this sometimes you
know you can't be going too long you
know I'm saying yeah we can't go too
long sometimes people run the light on
people shows even when they jokingly
tell them they're going to do it it
happens but you know what they flash you
a bunch and that's what we do in your
videos well we will just be totally so
again emails at crabbys podcast
gmail.com you have until November forth
for the video submission and listen if
you're thinking I don't know if it's a
good story not just send it to us please
we can use it and you know you guys r us
we are you wear one and we've speaking
of one we've got one of our favor one
and only turning the return of their
return of the Mack guys you know it I
don't even need an introduction but you
know her you know our dad Ronnie
Kirkland's favorite daughter please
welcome back to the craft fees jac kern
a jerk welcome back to the crappy Sheikh
Ahmed I thought you guys were doing some
intro that's why I was like oh let me
send this text that was the intro that
was your in I thought you'd entered for
a minute first we do all that and do
that well the fun when I'm not on your
time we don't want to waste your time so
if you need to text something I just
usually revealed to me that someone I
know lives a block away that's like a
friend of mine for it first of all we
didn't reveal it like you're like and
guess who lives at those whose on the
corner huh mom just happen to come up in
conversation finish your text it's so
good to have you back here it's decently
good to have you back and it's so
psyched to be back I know we've tried
both of our schedules got
crappy they did uh and but now this is
the first time we've been in a studio
that's true this is like that's true
Troy first of all intimidating are you
trying to say the last place at sickle
cells was not a studio oh no a different
kind of studio yes yeah in independent
studio I I agree all things common here
which you are also part of I am to do
you ever come here in record are you
always doing it somewhere else no I'm I
was in my room yeah on my I rig but I
think um maybe I'll do one here one time
like a super organized one where of like
Madeline why do you want to be so
organized Jen I don't I'd my podcast is
a disaster it's just me babbling I don't
there would be no it would feel weird to
do it in front of someone else mm-hmm so
that's why I just stay home and do it
well if there's anyone out there who
doesn't know why don't you tell them
about your podcast and your Twitter and
where they can find you well go to my
website jen kirkman com'on and in gin
and that's my twitter at jen kirkman
thank you my podcast it's not for
everyone so i will say with love not
offended of people don't like it it's
very ridiculous but it's called i seemed
fun the diary of jen kirkman and I just
toss them to myself for a week I mean
for a week seems like right now about
what went on that week it's very honest
is on I was funny and sometimes it is
but it has its own little community of
as you know people that latch on to
certain things you say that become
private jokes and you know all that's
organically happened so it's cool yeah
that's very cool yeah but I think if
people jump in they might be like I
don't know what I seem talking about
yeah yeah that's great not the best
salesperson the world ya mean listen X
whenever it's not for everybody haha you
don't like it I won't be offended no
need to tweet madman [ __ ] I get it's not
always funny you know but listen guys
fabulous five stars I that's what I have
people do on iTunes if they give it five
stars they have to write something awful
in the review like so either something
generic like I listened or they have to
write this is the worst episode ever
this is the worst podcast I've ever
heard but always has to be five stars
it's kind of like f the crab kind of
like it kind of sounds like maybe you
know what my buddy Jason is my I was
just telling you guys are white in his
house sitting in
that dope house yeah and he cooks all
the time for he lives he cooked for us
in South by Southwest oh yeah every
breakfast was just outstanding he's a
bit like he loves to cook yeah went to
be you and so he cooks all the time so
we decide to do was because he's not
always there he's a composer for TV
right so he's just staying at his
sister-in-laws because they have a great
studio there and so he cooks for the
family to get everyone on a schedule
right but he goes he's not always there
so he started instagram feed called chef
uncle Jason you can all follow it and
every time he cooks a meal he instagrams
it so that the he only did it for the
family right so they can look and be
like oh let's have that again let's have
that eat cook something different every
night also was just a reference yeah
yeah but all suddenly menu yeah exactly
an email will pop up and say oh your
friend started chef uncle Jason so
there's like a bunch of people falling
on so when he started he put up like
nine picks right away and I just went on
to everyone and commented of why I
wouldn't want that meal and then I just
put hashtag next time like a next time
but every like he put this amazing like
four-cheese lasagna like sorry man i'm
only about the five cheese's halfback
next thing could you lay up my
instrument but you know that there's
someone reading what you wrote and
thinking god that's rude there's also
another person looking at glitching I'm
with do say so right here there's
definitely that guy to like it's guys
like me man I'm with five he had like a
veggie plate with baby carrots and I
just wrote hey man no offense but he
goes the reason I would never eat this
meal is the same reason I don't I don't
eat veal and I don't eat baby carrots
hashtag this time no baby cows the very
care come on come on man Oh kirkland
what are you up to actually more time
are you up to yeah I want to kinda like
that I miss my parents haven't seen them
since December they came to Vegas in
February I tried to get them to come to
LA but I couldn't get they couldn't make
the extra 800 miles well they were like
we're tired that's not and I'm like they
were they did back to work now ya know
there I don't know what like they were
there in February for a week cuz they go
every week and they usually do visit me
for a day mm-hmm but this one day that
we all had free it would have been
easier if I went there because they
some like I don't know something with
some hotel here that some so boring I
mean they're hardcore game yeah so I
didn't go to visit them because I was
two days off on the road and I was like
I can't go to Vegas for two days and
then get on a plane on a Wednesday and
do five shows at some crap hole
somewhere mm-hmm and not have like
rested up so I was like I'll miss you
this time and then it's just my summer
certain happening on these things aren't
happening so now I can't do my usual
summer visit so I'll see them for like a
day in September and then i'll do some
holiday stuff with them yeah
thanksgiving and stuff well all's I know
is I'm at Foxwoods casino yeah so you've
partied with my parents a place your
parents frequent every week every week
day what is now that well my mother just
called and said they have to take a
month off starting now cuz it getting
very strict me about that points and you
know my parents like don't spend that
much money but they used to go so often
that they would get free yeah every
tickets to concerts or whatever and so
now they're loosening up on free hotel
stays and the points that you have to
earn it's getting more intense and I
don't know what's to believe my parents
like to kind of paint it like they're
victims of the system that is only meant
to truck you over yeah the casino isn't
isn't taking care of you like it's so
weird yeah I get a text from jen that
says hey can you put my dad on the list
for your show tonight he might be coming
and I was like are you kidding of course
and then of course it turns out like I'm
already too late my dad's already shown
up you know what I mean like an he got
the day wrong it was a whole thing he
and then yeah exactly i was backstage
and someone goes hey man that's some guy
here is Pete don't want to hear in a
casino and I go what [ __ ] yeah some
guy Ronnie and I go what or r on kirkman
I go yeah man no problem come on like
I'm like how you look bad you know and
AG did you tell them about the piece of
paper yet cuz he doesn't understand what
this podcast is and he really doesn't
know who you are you guys are his fans
he is not your fan I go for the story
you have to go find Jay and he wrote
down on a piece of paper your name just
Jay didn't he I can't all like all I
remember is he was wearing like knocking
around the piece of paper that says Jay
Larson he got there at when the show was
over
okay so like the show just and it sounds
like this guy's here so I come out and I
meet them and now like I'm saying
goodbye to everybody and anyone who's a
crab feast fan I'm like oh you're they
go hey man I listen every Tuesday and
I'm like oh man great see I go you knew
this is and they go know who would I go
veronique arkham man they're like holy
[ __ ] the mirror hey I'm not kidding you
anyone that was excited to see me at all
the second they found out Ronnie Kirk
rooms there was like do could we get a
picture haha Jay take it exactly yeah I
had no problem so much so that when so
tons everyone that was there that to see
me from the crab fees yeah they got to
meet Ronnie Kirkman and people were
stoked out of their mind they couldn't
believe that is great I couldn't believe
it so then Ronnie's having a drink and
he goes up let's have a drink and I go
all right I don't say he doesn't drink
Roger never drinks if he does he gets
really drunk off like two or three
because he drinks him all in a row and
then goes warm dizzy and then he sucks
man is going from here what does he
drink Cape Cotters yeah we were drinking
Cape Cod's that's where we I go all day
Cape kata yeah I don't even know what
it's really called it's called Cape Cod
it's in a cape cod vodka cran always it
always with the line yeah they've caught
oh man but what about a sea breeze that
is our G breeze is a vodka cran and
grapefruit well I remember I took my
parents to Dan Tana's once and we never
got seated even though we had a
reservation they they [ __ ] us over it
sucks and i was gonna palm them some
money and my dad was like you don't
[ __ ] do that like we get the table
fair and square or not we're not giving
these [ __ ] money for a thing they
should be doing already and I was like
that's not how it works but fine and so
we sat at the bar for a while just
waiting Michael who's Michael Michaels
the bartender there Michael Santana he
was a dick to my dad made a quad cape
codder he goes I don't know what that is
he goes vodka cranberry goes then he was
acting like no like I you can't just
make up a drink and I go it's vodka
cranberry with it line and the guy was
like I go sued nut don't don't mind what
it's called just put that in a glass for
my dad like I was getting so pissed you
[ __ ] how's it look ya don't mind what
it's called but that in a glass my
[ __ ] phone
eat mule and so they put it in and then
he was like he was so rude to him those
well Michael's been bar down there for
like 40 years and has like a stake in
the place aries i knows my boy Richard
yeah uh from cocking I go to Dan Tana's
with them all the time what is the Pablo
is Michael it was a younger man okay
then it was about Michael older and is
always drink in this Czechoslovakian
booze off the top shelf like you all
always do know them but like every time
i've been to denton is is either with
richard or richer put in the reservation
and like i've shown there friday night
with richard reservation like oh yeah
right here we go we sit down next to amy
poehler and like just get should i
hooked me up I wish I'd known uh yeah
anyway so we're sitting there drinking
Cape Cod us you know I mean and we have
a couple and then I go uh you know I go
what what are you doing now and it's a
man I go wisdom I go with you lady and
give a sh playing the slots Oh bingo
maybe she's in the bingo hall I kept
texting Jade it's okay to ditch him if
he's bothering you and I kept calling my
dad leave Jay alone and I was having a
blast a lot of the hang up so then we
forget how we part ways but he goes he
goes I might come by tomorrow night too
and I go do I go yeah oh yeah that's
what he did he only showed up at the end
so he could say meet everybody and he
came for the fell he came for the
fanfare not this yes I do you know that
I did not know this yes he came out with
me my friends to bowling and your mom
showed up she straight from the bottle
hall wait nobody second this is the
second night he was there friday night
that's all I know about yes so then
saturday all my friends from high school
are coming up here comes Ronnie goes
maybe I'll stop by tomorrow maybe hey
Sherlock baby i'll stop by can I just
say I called my dad then when they were
driving home Sunday I go so you saw Jay
ago did you ever go back see the comment
you goes yeah I wait a couple of drinks
Franny and you know we left we didn't do
much and we seem we saw mom took that
picture we sent you I go that's what he
said to me he blatantly lied to me
unless he just didn't what I have no
idea he came back Saturday night didn't
I back saturday met people afterwards
and I go Ronnie we're all going bowling
you want to come ball you're going
to fix all my god god love first of all
he knows what's going on he loves it he
loves it all he's no he knows that he
doesn't know what this is I guess he
doesn't know how why it happened dude
people were saying him Ronnie what's the
internet saying about you meant like
[ __ ] like that didn't over that you woke
up can't remember yeah it was the
internet saying about me yeah they know
all about his brain and dream yeah they
know shitty he doesn't know no so I
leave him he goes I say he's walking
with all of us and we're gonna go down
to this bowling alley and Fox was and we
get to the escalating goes i'ma go I'm
gonna go see what the wife's doing and I
go all right Ronny well we'll be down
here you know Bubba was like I probably
won't see about I'm like all right so
we're bowling 20 minutes later here's
Ronny and your mom come down state he
goes I had to bring her over to meet you
and I got a pleasure to meet you in she
goes I go how was everything good Bubba
talking for like 10 minutes and then he
bounced are they bounced okay they
didn't Bowl no honey hahaha he's out
there arguing overlaying put up a 220
man put up a tooth warning was my mom
night see oh she was a sweetheart yeah
hilarious the two of them I mean it's
the last weekend they both had like a
big blowout weekend at Foxwoods but
separately my mom saw Boy George by
herself one night I love your fair you
know what I was just the thing I was
just about to say the thing I loved
about them is they're going to the same
place but then they just go and say hey
you do your thing I mean my thing we'll
meet up here they probably eat their
meals together what yeah yeah they do
their own thing I mean there's 77 they
finally got it working now but it's like
that makes sense yeah yeah but they um
but my friend uh Chris franjola was I
think saw your Instagram or my Instagram
or someone's and he just texted me
you're home by yourself on a friday at
midnight and your dad's actually the
life you should be drinking with friends
three you know 3am all right I think I
feel like your dad I talked for a while
I think I said something to him like
Ronnie oh i think i did i said i go you
know what you two got a dial men you're
great parents did a great job because
that great job all my daughter's a
divorce as he said something
I can't remember what he said I think I
said something I think I said sudden him
like what a great example you guys are
for your kids and he goes are you
kidding all my daughters and avoid none
of them you know they're all I thought
many as there are you 303 are ya by the
way there aren't only three divorces
between the three of us mm-hmm there are
six how many children between the three
of you three all my sister my older
sister takes the prize she has all the
divorces and all the kids okay but yeah
that's hilarious eMac like they care
that we're divorced like I think he
loves you guys no matter what that's
what doesn't matter what but I wonder if
he he I wonder if they are bummed for
themselves that we are or if they think
we're bundoora I don't know sometimes I
asked him and they're like that I might
ever but that's like that's a little
couple drinks in Ronnie maybe yeah yeah
they're all divorce yeah he suddenly is
like Artie Lange toxic our dealings no
no I'll [ __ ] divorced I also think
somebody said to him I think someone
when he had to go one I think one of the
crab feast van gogh's what he gotta go
mow a couple fairways Ronnie IV into
that he didn't hear it were they hidden
with the cut list they had to be hitting
them with the gay people were like
where's the Cutlass wears a leather
jacket like he was getting hit with
every single thing he came back I need
know what the Cutlass I mean he knows he
had a Cutlass I don't think he gets what
that I mean I don't know you gave him
the shirt I saw she was very confused
Jennifer I got a shirt with a cutlass on
it but that's not my Cutlass that's not
what it looks like I don't know what
does be an accurate rendition it's it's
a kiss and inspiration inspiration
Pilates guys don't had an anal is a
skill game the RK in the sunscreen yeah
Tommy windshield lot people gonna know
that's my name and I go no no and he
goes okay cuz he was like nervous they'd
find out where he lived like he's like
how'd they know where I lived like no I
gave them your head like you didn't know
what was happening my mom had to explain
it and she doesn't really know what's
going on right but she's better with
explaining things to so the other thing
he did was which would be an the
ultimate baller move if you're doing
this on purpose but I don't think you I
think he was just being a gentleman he
goes
we buy a drink and I go rania I drink
for free man i got let me buy you a
drink you know cuz we always drink for
free or doing clubs or bars or whatever
and so I don't know if it's a ball
moving his part of his way to get me to
buy him a drink by being like a let me
buy a drink I'm agrani me buy you a
drink can he sat at the bar and he just
like doesn't the box he doesn't instant
let's sit at the bar and my friends were
like so dying to bro out my friends from
like high school uh are we gonna go hang
out with you who is this guy here like I
go to drive it and I think I only had
one friend of mine from high school that
listens to the podcast has or might know
who Ronnie is because the restroom life
economica was the larsons podcast right
right um and one of them like do this
Ronnie Kirkman and my buddy Joey who
listens all time was like holy [ __ ] is
unbelievable your other piquant sign-in
the autographs please say one slip that
I don't know maybe he did but yeah
that's kind of an old-school move the
autograph well no my parents have some
fame they come to my gigs to try to get
noticed and stuff but you know they'd
have to now that they're on my podcast a
little bit here and there they've got
some fame but mostly with me it's I'll
show in my Twitter feed when people talk
about it but but here's what the crab
feast fans I don't think they're the
leather jacket thing is a controversy to
me he doesn't wear a leather jacket no
cared of 11 he's scared of right on
leather jackets but people are like
Ronnie's rolling up in the Cutlass in a
leather jacket no I don't know if that's
an additional it's just throwing in mind
that they threw it in a key or maybe
they felt like he was driving away from
that house to go get his and now he's
back yeah but he's never wanted it's
just a way of clumping it all together
it's always a windbreaker he's never
been in Wilson's know what's Wilson
that's allow you to the other by golly
will celebrate emotions no we gotta tell
them he rolls up in a windbreaker that
says needham golf club so we got to
change the narrative when he showed up
to the shows he just had a blue sweater
on with a red collared like polo
underneath yeah like couldn't he look
like a Kennedy he looked at the Kennedy
I mean an old beat-up one yeah well then
he's like Canada you know what he did
have that we
all commenting on what unbelievable hair
whoo Ronny k yeah he's got like a good
head of hair that still got color yeah
he's looking like brown hair and a good
like good part to it yay 7777 that's how
i asked him i think he dies it no does
he die I think he would know how he gets
pedicures but it doesn't dye his hair
thank you hi Jen I gotta get my pedicure
today he like got so obsessed with it my
mom got him a free one and he was like
hi this is great good hela I so he goes
to Fox let's get this pedicure oh that's
killer they just do everything at
Foxwoods everything did they get their
hair done oh really yeah my mom gets her
hair done there she gets all her
Christmas presents there we do you need
anything also a mall owner is like that
big yeah there's like a Sephora so
she'll get like Rick green makeup or
whatever Oh their whole life is there
yeah so my mom cuz I don't know what
we're gonna do this month without it I
go well I mean there's literally a
commuter rail train in their backyard
that that goes right into Boston it's
only five stops 20 minutes I go go into
the city and like go to the pond dirt
have a nice dinner no that's too far but
they'll drive ninety minutes to
Connecticut on the wildest freeways at
rush hour and she's like your father
night we don't like to do that we only
like to go to foxwoods oh alright
alright I mean they should just
grandfather them in is like they get I
they get so much press from me saying
foxwoods no [ __ ] all the time yeah so
[ __ ] them have you done foxes I did it
once but um I affiliate it with like a
bad memory so I don't go back yeah and
it was one of those things like not the
show wasn't bad or anything but two
things happen where I was co-headlining
with my friend Josh wolf and we were
gonna eat it was like a couple years ago
like four years ago so I hadn't really
started touring a lot yet but um but we
were all tour together with chelsea
lately like because we all wrote on the
show and so we were supposed to like one
show i would headline one show he would
same amount of time but just switching
up who goes first or last and he Josh
kept saying to me like the guy won't let
you go last and he's like he's afraid to
tell you but he doesn't think women can
headline and he's like so it's on me to
tell you and I feel like a dick but he's
like I told him no he's like so if you
want to
like we can both go up to Michael [ __ ] I
don't want to go last anyway yeah so who
cares but good but his sex isn't helping
mom out I'll have a drink so it was but
I always remembered that I'm like this
guy's not getting my business yeah he's
like getting my but you should I promote
should I was up about the [ __ ] out the
casino oh but I don't even know if
that's how true that is or if it he
changed his mind since then Boris is
josh won the headline oh I doubt it no I
mine is just you know what let's give me
Josh wolf get ass brother take your hat
off permanently sewn on Thursday um no
so yeah I would go back but it's like
I'd rather it I know I'm gonna see my it
actually would be perfect I could hang
with my parents yeah form there may be
due Mohegan Sun I mean see where works
out Mohegan sounds like huge isn't it I
guess it's it's nicer than who knows
they're right next so you can see the
other how many shows you do [ __ ] what's
31 Friday night to saty yeah to friday
to Sandy no I think I did one thursday
one friday to saturday Oh too much time
there yeah 3 nights I can't remember I
gondia yeah you know I golf friday i
golf saturday left Sunday yeah I can't
leave you didn't see Ronnie k on the
course he invited we got it he will cost
every week in there I invited him my boy
Joey was there with me and I said why
don't you come golfing tomorrow and he's
like am I mean the my phone he might
have been bullshitting you because he's
kind of a snob and doesn't think
anyone's a good golfer um I'd smoke him
I don't know what you're I'm decent i'm
playing your 10 handicap right now i
don't know what your dad your dad just
plays handicap I don't know what he does
I don't even know Jim oh I is that a
joke cuz he's old well he's getting
better you know what what sucks about
his golf game even was happening when he
was young the terrible Potter terrible
really I mean that's the whole thing I
know that's what I'm good at putting
yeah i mean i'm actually a good driver
too if I ITI off with a niner and I
don't like the wood really and I can go
about 150 yards with your nine iron
mm-hmm Wow good job I'll show you i have
a video of me on facebook doing if you
don't believe me but I don't to show you
now but it does exist was it dry for
show
putt for dough yeah they say it's the
hard part oh well yes Lily you know I
was gonna I wanted to be a lady pro
golfer I probably said that on here
before no I was one of the rings of that
before you didn't know that that was one
of the many things isn't you when you're
a kid and you're like for me it wasn't
so linear as I Cohen be a comedian I
just wanted to be something performing
you were like Mozart [ __ ] it Dinah Shore
yeah maybe when I was like five or six
we'd watch women's golf I thought these
women looked so cool like the way they
strut I didn't know like they are cool
yeah like I didn't know it was like uh
not that cool to play golf like I don't
know it's kind of dorky in a weird way
but they seem like badass [ __ ]
I don't think and the way they can i
watch women's golf the way they put that
marker down and when all the balls are
on the on the green and you put your
mark I thought that was so called a
little moves they did in my quantum you
want to know something yeah i've been
using um old coin for as my ball marker
because I had a buddy that used to use
this old silver dollar and I was like oh
that's the coolest yeah my dad passed
like three months ago in our two months
ago and I went home okay thanks and I
went home when Ronnie could be there for
you as a stereo I've had a lot of
circuit but the one thing that I got I
got I got a couple things but his wife
said oh these are all your dad's old
coins that these are his favorites if
you want taken why do you call your mom
his wife that's [ __ ] up anyway it's
not my dad reaping huh so joking say
anyway anyway I lost that coin I used it
one round you use a bunch of coins or
silver dollars an antique antique dealer
my dad so he had tons of old coins so it
wasn't for the express purpose of
golfing you then no yeah she just had
this like all these of you dad's
favorite old huh so I took a bunch of
them and like one of them I com he use
this is my ball marker and I lost it
fine one day I know I think it's a sign
sign he left this point left malayalam
me around you know what month don't take
my boy you so much 1905 nickel silver
nickel the ghost of your dad took that
ship is a 1905 and get the dating sites
able given this
do you think did you take any more yeah
i took a i took a bunch i have like some
like spanish 1700 coins a lot of crazy
stuff you should just put like a
doubloon out there just change these in
your big bang right there behind your
ball you guys and your dad's kill me i
hopped did I tell this story lesson but
listening to you on it you said you guys
need dad's kill me both our dads are
dead that's what I mean it makes me sad
I was in a hotel room and I had this
crazy in some well it's not crazy but
the type of insomnia I get as I sleep
hard for a couple hours and then for no
reason i'll wake up at three and i keep
thinking and off all right back asleep I
don't need to take a sleeping pill or a
benadryl I'll far and then at 7am I'm
like [ __ ] I should have taken the pill
you know what so this one night I'm like
I just need to listen to a two person
conversation like deep conversation that
will just kind of like lull me into
relaxation and I'm like sick leurs being
interviewed on something and like oh
this would be good he has his good
stories and and i'm like falling asleep
as i can then my dad and i walked in the
room and he died in front of me and some
crazy sad story i'm like what the [ __ ] I
was bawling my neck stood me yeah and I
was like you remember it and then one
day I'm just wearing a t-shirt in the
Chelsea Lately writers room that says
pan am and my friend took my picture I
put on Instagram and he texts me like
hey real good to see that logo my dad
used to work for Pan Am lots of memories
I'm like stop it it was right after that
to ya Jesus you guys I still have Pan Am
like work shirts of his in a work jacket
stuff I've got a winter jacket that when
I go to real places like Montana yeah
because it was the one that they would
wear in the tarmac in the middle of
winter its got like a bladder in it that
but like almost like a Vesta bones lie
inside then the jacket around the things
bad hand am been hitting him up for life
lobby I got some vintage [ __ ] they have
you know what else I have I pulled out
the other day why do you believe
everything um it's really weird I found
you to fly you fly obviously quite a bit
but I pulled out the other day we have a
Pan Am blanket the blank they used to
give you when you got on the plane oh my
god he's a [ __ ] it's it's I mean it's
ten times bigger than the thing they
give you now yes so big it's a blanket
and everyone probably got one right
everyone you're gonna go ah yeah see I
remember uh-oh friend of mine had a
jacket that said Eastern
airlines which doesn't exist anymore and
he said someone came up to him in an
airport like hey man are you guys hiring
like I'm an out-of-work like flight
attendant I'm just you know I've never
heard of this airline is it new he's
like no dude oh it's the oldest airline
ever I had the same thing happened to me
I was wearing the Wright brothers
t-shirt mom angela 20-minute commute to
come Kitty Hawk man oh I wanted to be a
lady pro golfer and my I could have been
hooked up and I actually kind of regret
this in a weird what my dad goes as a
greenskeepers daughter you can go to any
college and study golf for free I didn't
know that anybody any state university
or something full run study golf if you
if you go it get accepted as a golf you
can get a scholarship or some kind of
scholarships keepers otters or something
and so I was like all right on i started
taking golf lesson because it was like a
country song i was a green creepy but i
didn't get the fat full rad no we went
we would golf every night like three
holes from like dusk to like complete
darkness and i was pretty good but my
dad would get friend he never got
frustrated but the one time that he was
not the coolest person that he could be
was like me golfing like ah that sucks
but like no help helping me just like
gin it gotta do it this way and I'm like
all right hang on and I'm like I'm gonna
take actual lessons cuz you're bumming
me out so I took lessons from the golf
pro but I think it was just I was the
wrong age when you're 12 and you just
feel awkward in your own body it's weird
to have a grown man who has to put his
arms around you and help you hold the
thing and put his hands over yours I
felt creeped out and I know this guy
wasn't creeping on me he was a nice
normal person but I was just the wrong
age of it started at eight that would
have been different or started at 14 but
at 12 I was like I don't like this guy
touching me and I just like didn't care
anymore yeah it's probably probably
didn't help that you address his Mozart
easy he's like I can't win up to touch
you can you get home if you get this
watching for your piano down here God
and of allergic to this powder wait
these are not stop over here right God
so on the putting green when the members
would cut off i would putt with them
let's my summer vacation was just I
would just go down to the green and putt
and we're still in Massachusetts this is
at the gall to protect their backyard oh
right on your backyard yeah I walk out
the house just go the petting green
every day I spent three hours putting my
whole life as a kid so I think that's
why I'm not bad now yeah and then uh but
then I didn't become a lady pro golfer
at every once in my dad would be like
yeah I would have been good but he's you
know but I go I did the other lesbian
jump welcoming the other fluffy not gay
but ya know but I that's right you heard
me say comedian ya know I said fee
Montano I was a comedian who happens to
be female golfer happens three women
that would be great if there was a
ladies tea for comedy like hey as long
as people are gonna think I'm not as
good let me do 10 minutes from way back
it's like they groom them way back in
the air you have a laugh button you can
yeah yeah yeah everything has just set
up for me let's I'm gonna introduce that
anyway sorry um we were talking before
we got on and you said you had a great
bombing story and I'm dying to hear
though because for you to say that I
know something went down well you know
when like there's bombing where it's
just not your night but maybe the people
are fans of yours are they would be in
under normal circumstances but you
didn't say it right and then maybe you
got off on a bad foot and because you
didn't say one joke right then you're
kind of giving off this vibes that you
hate them and they're kind of like
defensive and it's going okay but you're
like I'm sort of eating it but they're
like haha but you're like no I know I
can do better I did this last night you
did that was like last night that I had
dead silence like a TED talk as I say
and someone else said it once what
happened to you listen no I mean I just
what happened last night I had haven't
done stand-up in so long yeah and i'm
like i did this show and i have all it
was all new material you know so I'm
like looking at it and I'm doing it and
I'm getting like a little chuckles and a
little bit of this a little of that and
I'm say I'm like no [ __ ] way man this
deserves way more than that yeah so then
I started like digging into them a
little bit and then driving home
I they need to give more and that was
just getting worse and I didn't care and
I just said I'm like I'm not going I'm
not leaving i'm getting a light i ran
the light and i'm like in the light I
saw the light like I've four minutes
what show is no I ran the light but to
keep talking to them not to tell I got a
life for two minutes I beat my two
minutes and there's two minutes later I
got the light again so it's been two
minutes pass on us let's get off and I'm
so annoyed I'm like I was annoyed it
like I hadn't done the preparation to
give the best performance like a give I
was annoyed that this was new material
and it wasn't working I was annoyed that
they they didn't have a chance to
understand who I was and all the stuff
so nice like I'm gonna I'm gonna put it
back in you you Fox I'm gonna be like
because you can't get up there and be
like ah PS haven't done stand-up in two
months this is all brand new but you
know what I mean yeah you can't I think
it's the most frustrating thing when
you're starting out in comedy especially
if you are right about your instinct
you're like I know I'm good I just don't
have enough practice yet and I didn't
write this stuff out yet but I know I'm
going to be a funny comedian you guys
got to get on board and that's what
sucks about it when you are then
suddenly years later a professional
community who is funny and can win over
anyone and you're not it like takes you
back to them like you guys don't know
what's inside me but you know when to
list your resume like excuse me on Conan
told this story bro need up Brody will
Brody would ya Brody Stevens enlisted
for in the hangover and then get your
eyes out of funny feeling oh so oh this
what happen to me so I'm in Montreal at
the at the Comedy Festival which is such
as you know amazing to be invited sure
but I auditioned for 12 years and got
turned down yeah and so um they give me
pity bookings now like not in a bad way
they're like oh [ __ ] we're sorry we were
kind of like this to you so now I'm like
but it's by the way they've never said
that this is just all in your head
assuming that's what there's no no oh
they said that literally they've I've
had conversations with the guy my
manager has no no because they never had
me and then three years ago Chelsea
Handler got this award at Montreal and
she was allowed to bring three guests
and she brought all the girls that wrote
for her and it was like private jet like
all hooked up she's a baller yeah anyone
there at that level that's where all the
money is going so when they're like you
can comp
your own flight you're like that because
you got a private jet for Dave Chappelle
yeah until see so we go and i go to my
manager I've never been to Montreal I
can't show up there with everyone
running around hey jen kirkman assuming
when they run into me probably that I'm
there to perform my ego cannot handle
just me going I'm here as Chelsea's
guests like I'm not a comedian at that
point for 1314 years and so my manager
was like maybe we can just get you some
spots and other people show so I was
like that would be fine i don't to do my
own like one person charity and so they
were like wait Jen's ever been here and
she's like no remember every year you
denied her so we just stopped
auditioning because it was getting
humiliating like they'd be like oh
you're you're already in just run your
set at the Laugh Factory at 7pm you know
on a day of the week that doesn't exist
you're like no one will be there and
they're like no they don't mind if no
one laughs they just want to see the set
and then I would go I would bomb because
no one literally I performed for three
people once those three people were the
Montreal people and they weren't
laughing and there's no audience and
then I'd get a call they just don't
think you're ready i'm like it's year 13
you said I was just running my set oh no
and so anyway that kept happening to the
humiliating levels and they're like oh
we didn't really shouldn't been in it
now they could have been bullshitting
but my manager was like she's from
Boston originally and she doesn't take
any [ __ ] she's like well you did know
and so this is what's happening what are
you gonna do and they're like here she
can have these spots and next year which
was a couple years ago and she can come
back and do like one night of her own
show she's like great so while that
happened and then last year when I came
back they don't they really did say like
we're so sorry and we neglected you all
these used but going now I go back and
do like little weird things but when I
go back it's not i'm at the point
already where what montreal could get me
i already have like i have a road career
a little bit and people in TV i guess no
me and they'll listen to me if I have a
good idea but they're not about to
discover me like that's already there
going there for the younger people so I
don't mean it in a negative way I just
mean you're kind of past your prime so
if you think it's fun to go and hang out
then great but I don't I don't like to
go and hang out and I don't like the
image that everything's going well and
I'm part one of the people that's
invited to the festival my situation is
so bizarre so I kind of hate being there
if that makes sense so who cares that's
that's my justification of it but there
was this gala I was on the Alan Cummings
gala which
Gallas at Montreal are these like I'm
just saying the audience like 2,000 seat
theaters they tape it for television it
airs in Canada who cares if you do well
or not the audience is brightly lit
which is like a comedians nightmare as
you know and so but the Alan [ __ ] is
like gay Broadway showtunes guy so
everyone on the show had a little bit of
a gay vibe or what or was blatantly gay
or woman so it was like perfect for me
and I know my daughter's a lesbian you
wanted to be a golf Oh Lizzie all the
way and she's divorced come on put it
together and you really do put it
together it should be I should be so I
go I'm so I'm wearing this little like
leather shorts and fishnet stockings
because I'm trying to dress like you
dressed you dress the awesome I just
also for the his audience but that's for
his ideas which he's starring in
cabarets I thought and I had this like
sparkly jacket that they wouldn't let me
wear because they're like it's gonna
[ __ ] with the camera I'm like I'll
forget it so just kinda where this all a
little leather outfit was cute but I
wouldn't normally perform in that unless
I was playing like a punk rock club
where suddenly the outfit can look punk
rock or if you wear it at a big gala it
looks like theatrical but a normal
comedy show that would look to sexy like
you're maybe not that funny and like
what's this chick tryin to do you know
think you've got to think about that
stuff sometimes so it's like you know if
you wore a suit to the wrong thing you
might look like a stiff you know Horus
so I get there and then at the last
minute they're like hey do you want to
do this Howie Mandel gala so the Alan
Cummings one goes great I killed they
let me do whatever material I want to go
for the easy stuff I'm out see ya seven
minutes hero right here so then they're
like come back at ten do the howie
mandel gala and it's howie hosting and
heavy hitters on it Jeff Ross Jim Breuer
blah blah blah so I go great and they go
it's gonna air on the CW network in
America and we're gonna pay you like
good money I was like perfect I'd
already lost some money I'd cancel some
shows I love picking up a gig like that
like a night while you're sure it was
like the day before but just condensing
it but yeah it really was last minute so
I get to the rehearsal and I brought
these pants that have a pattern but it's
not a crazy pattern like you can't wear
those on the camera wool you know
explode
right look weird on camera I go I wore
these on TV in Australia they go the
cameras are different there no they're
not even accents ears yeah different I
was like well get some of those awesome
we thought about me cameras go the other
way yeah so I go well I the only thing
after where is he shorts but it's
outfits not right for the show like it
looks great so some creepy sound guy was
like oh think it looks great i might
know of course you do but you're not
understand what I'm saying so then I'm
like I already know so they go so then I
find out there's no time to go back and
get something else you're just you're
there those are the only two besides
like other things that have patterns on
them that's where the camera acceptable
yeah only things American can yeah
American camera Canadian cameras airing
in America all kinds of it's a lot a lot
a lot of lot of loose so I go alright
alright but I just think like okay let's
say Dave Chappelle showed up in some
funky pattern they're gonna be like Dave
we got to get you to change their men's
wearhouse me but like the camera will
adjust today so you know in general it's
fine they're just being weird so I'm
already in an outfit that I don't feel
good and so right away I'm uncomfortable
it's the worst yeah and I'm projecting
some image i'm not trying to predict
then I find out before I go on like the
day before but they said you can't do
any material that has ever been on TV
anywhere ever so the only material I
have that's appropriate would be stuff
I've already done I go I have nothing
that's not dirty like or i can do new
stuff that's been going well on the road
to my specific fan base but it's not
ready yet and they're like no it's gonna
be great just do it and I'm like okay so
i have like I found one old joke that
I've never done on on TV not that I've
done so much TV that's how little
material there is that is t be
acceptable so I go alright i have this
two-minute story about my friends kid
and then i'll do this bit about a guy
yelling nice shoes at a car at me down
south like it's actually funny story-- i
won't get into it but a guy pulled up
and yelled out the window can I say
something creepy to you and I and it's
this whole internal struggle like you're
supposed to say yeah in which of course
I digs I'm an idiot and then all it
turns out as he wanted to compliment my
shoes but then he goes with this long
story i'm not gay and I'm married but
I've got
thing for shoes and he's like Tommy's
life story and it's just like a really
funny story can i pee on your shoes so
we end up having this great conversation
where I'm like you know it's totally
cool to compliment a woman on her shoes
like you know it to be so paranoid and
don't get out of that car yeah just
don't get that guy and I'm thinking like
what is he going through at home where
like his wife is like whatever it was in
my mind as a funny story and it's weird
they're all flats we got somebody else
in here everything looking at flats
exactly Theresa I would it kill you to
take off her sneakers hey listen put on
a nice sandal for summer my wife's a pro
golfer oh no she keeps going out a long
way ain't everything Brenda what do you
think that's about what do you think's
going on it spikes everywhere she found
some cool coin though on the golf course
1805 makes unbelievable so all right so
this is unlike fine new material outfit
I don't want mm-hmm I get there it
starts at ten-thirty it's now quarter to
midnight the show's still going on
everyone in the audience is like 50 and
above french-canadian people there's
2,000 people there they've been there
forever Jeff Ross goes on before me they
go they give him the longest time Jeff
do about 12 if he hit 15 that's cool he
does 30 does he do material or is he
talked about in the audience talks
people in the audience which in a good
you know it exhausts the audience I mean
that it also changes the vibe and a lot
more people don't notice when I always
tell people that open from when I was
recording my alma the host was doing
crower can I go go do what are you doing
no it changes the dynamic what happens
is the audience is expecting everybody
to do that and when you're doing crowd
work it's so spontaneous and in the
moment and it's it's like super super
personal some yeah yeah and it's a
little magical because it's happening
right then and there but guess what we
bust our ass to write stuff and perfect
it to perform so when you do follow
crowd comedians it's it's just a
different way because they're just like
oh you're gonna patronize us with this
written [ __ ] like Jeff came out and
exactly like humans by talking to us you
know so he did a half hour that and I
think there's an
satori energy where you're watching
people get up live on stage and then
when it's over you're like I'm satiated
like you dunt like you just had dessert
and so I come out and he brought people
on stage I mean it was Oh Jeff did yeah
so ha juggling children yeah literally
there's children I mean there's all
kinds of fun stuff happening bring the
family it's a great set so then this
woman comes up to me she goes how he
wants to do he's just learning periscope
you know that camera actually he wants
to do some fun stuff he wants to meet
you and you got off stage and just do
some fun behind-the-scenes stuff with
year ago well that's kind of cool like
I've never met him like that's nice I
cocaine grain she goes and then there's
a CW executive Jeff who says he's never
met you he just wants to say hi after
your set I go okay and I just go to her
I go I have this feeling i'm going to
bomb and i go i go i know it sounds
crazy but i just need to say this to you
because you just said all these things
that I know you think are exciting for
me but just I want to let you know that
I already know it's gonna go gone so why
you know if you can see all right now
she's pointing New York right now oh I
don't want it to be embarrassing that we
just had this exciting conversation
about all these famous people and
network executives at want a piece of me
after and then I'm gonna go out and eat
[ __ ] you're gonna feel weird I already
know and she's like don't say that I go
you're not you don't understand
comedians I go forget it Oh fine catch
it a bit yeah see on the other side I
like I wish you'd been there so I could
say cousin like fortune beamster was her
but she was in write back stage so
couldn't say to any other comedian yeah
watch this it's about to go down and
it's not one of those things where my
negative energy made it happen I was
having a psychic moment I walk out
they're done they're already like this
they hate the outfit there another date
the element hate it I say nice things in
my conversion there's fresh so good to
be here yeah like a friend or and I do
this story but the guy now he normally
just me go can I say something real
creepy to you gets a laugh silence and
then I just kept going silence and son
and I have to finish this story acting
like it's going on that's the thing
another thing about stories that no out
members might not know like when I did
the first time I did a story on
television they were like I remember
Kumail said to me goes what were you
gonna do if two minutes and it wasn't
going well and I'm like I never even
thought about because when you start a
story you have an to finish yeah unless
you're like doing some show that you
don't really care about you like now you
know what let's move on to something
else ya dig out of that hole 0 and the
in each you know like you know like
every 20 seconds of the story there is a
solid punch right so you but you can't
end on that laughs cuz it wouldn't make
sense you're like that's it if you
didn't get the punches earlier you're
not gonna get him later no so they
weren't laughing any and so then I just
go it's probably about three four
minutes and and then I start a story
about my friend wanted me to help her
put her kid to bed and like I look so
unlikable right now but if they were on
my side they would realize how annoying
my friend is being in this story but but
they don't and so they're just like and
I go uh can we stop right here I go I
want you guys to know just so that you
don't feel bad for me because if you
don't think I'm funny that's cool but I
just don't you go home and be like what
was that I'm a professional comic i just
got off a tour i have a Netflix special
like I'm gonna be your cup of tea but
just don't feel bad for me I do get to
do this for a living is like I didn't I
didn't care anymore I'm like huh [ __ ] yo
car for me Argentina I mean where are we
but Montreal y'all got a song for that
oh wells you know you get that you get
the sentiment they go up so they laughed
I go all are just that by lambda I go
don't you start laughing with me now
yeah that's what I love that cuz you do
you like oh [ __ ] ya back you so I go
it's like suddenly like a man coming
back into your life you're like oh okay
finally you know so I go I go hey if
you're gonna laugh at that then you're
gonna laugh that this [ __ ] i wrote which
is actually [ __ ] funny and i'll be i
go you guys I got four more minutes to
go your tell ya I love that you're I
just breaking it down you took all to
thousands of people put them right here
yeah look I just need to be straight
with ya I just give me and I go some
executive I go this gonna air in America
on this big Network no I don't care for
it there you know like that's I don't
even here nor there but I go some
executives waiting to talk to me
backstage I go I can't
go Jeff I called him out from the stage
I think I used to pretend name let's
call him again real quick Jeff joke it
was such a big new floor liner yes it
was that doesn't include Jen Kirk will
you really [ __ ] screamed out for
sweetie but I used to pretend name but
chefs like I'll get the [ __ ] out of here
man geez i got right I go jet there's
some guy named Jeff wants meet me
backstage ago you guys now because of
you I can't look him in the eye aggress
I don't know yeah I go now I'm letting
him know with this I'm not gonna
combined you later and I told Kelly
before I came out here this was gonna
happen she what hair you did say you
just let him game audion I had I oh so
then I did the last store thought it
finished my story about my friend
putting her kid to bed and they got a
little bit of chuckles and I go thank
god this is over a good night I walk off
stage of my agents back there and he
wasn't really paying attention and I go
that was brutal anyway no it was great i
go did you really watch you guys no not
really i go literal silence he goes oh
[ __ ] i go they self to pay me right he
goes yeah I go are you mad he goes I
don't give a [ __ ] and so then I'm so
then I noticed they didn't escort me to
the right with howie mandel like they
said i went right back and I go how he
doesn't do that thing anymore and they
go no and I go I don't have to talk to
that CW guy do I and they go no but they
make you stay into a curtain call and I
was like ah I had to get up at three
thirty in the morning to get a plane it
was like 1230 now and I was like but
they didn't know that but I was tired
and I was like I just bombed I don't
want to be a [ __ ] and ask another favor
it was like can I not do the curtain
call and the woman that produces show
goes I don't totally understand if you
just want to get out of here and not
show your face during the colonel why I
go I really don't want to I go thank you
sir cuz I totally understand one of
those nights and I just left was like
peace out you should have come out for
the curtain call with just two middle
fingers what's up jack oh my god
colors eggs I was just so embarrassed
cuz like Jim Breuer went on after me and
I've never I'd wait wait yeah what was
more uncomfortable the Mozart bombing or
the Montreal bombing Montreal Mozart I
was like so happy to be who I was yeah
you weren't even comfy you were more
call to wonder Mozart out you are your
TV I mean I'm like this is the wrong
outfit you guys this is Alan Cummings
gay gala outfit but yeah so I am I have
a little Google Alert on my name but I I
usually don't read much unless I know
it's a good one and someone told me and
then I'm like oh I'd all kind of read
that but I just saw like the little
headline come up like blah blah blah
like strong show jen kirkman's difficult
set that's all I sonics don't meet him I
don't want to read it yeah it's too real
I'm I wonder if you could have another
hopefully they're not gonna air it no
they're definitely not gonna hear that
but after you got them a little bit when
you said to him don't laugh now if you
said all right now and then started
redid that story that would have been
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] if you went for
you really committed yeah and oh and
then got I mean I mean it's the one of
those like you heard about that Hedberg
half hour you've heard about head burn
our you've heard that yeah Hedberg was
doing his half hour and he was 10 Comedy
Central yeah he was yes working anyway
started talking about wired why did they
invite a bunch of people who don't know
who I am to my show cuz they just
papered it the wrong right okay so then
did so then he went sat down the back
says you guys I can't believe this
having during my comedy central half
hour he's like 15 minutes in so he got
up and went to the front and started
doing old materials i doing all his old
stuff and got him and then goes all
right and then started the whole thing
again and then did it and they laughed
then they laugh i think that would have
been brilliant if i did that cuz then at
least out of a three-minute story they
could have aired that cuz I'm not gonna
air all seven minutes well then you were
to run at that point used to run the
light yeah yeah [ __ ] it I gotta do what
I gotta do I mean that show was already
going so I mean the show is really all
Howie Mandel doing is and to be honest
with you it was a more well I
interrupted you look II sang Jim Breuer
you you oh I just think I was
embarrassed cuz he went on after me not
that he was watching me but I hopefully
one you
no how comedians I really like you ever
again he went out to anyone you better
lay off never know and any community
probably saw that Pro is like I [ __ ]
love that she's calling them out right
now you know I hope so I felt so
embarrassed i just wanted to get the
folk oh yeah nobody even watches
everyone said like I get offstage and
there's like he wasn't the next guy but
he was back there and then like the next
guy is about to go on a mic and they're
like what am I go oh was rough and
they're like as if I was watching yeah
nobody cares but yes it was one of those
things are like that but then everyone I
tried to tell who wasn't a committee was
like I'm sure wasn't that been like no
I'm good saw me no no do don't get it
the funny story I'm loving it I knew
when it was happening this is amazing
like not because it's gonna be a good
story but this is so bizarre that a 40
psychiatrist couldn't figure out what
how about here it's just one of those
[ __ ] things and it's great that it
was televised and it was great that it
was supposed to be a big deal yeah and
it's great that they threw a little bit
of money at me because I had to cancel a
show and go to a hospital cuz I had a
reaction to some medication what
happened and so I needed to make up for
that money so perfectly was like an
angel thing um you're like what's an
angel thing but like you know like I
guess kismet I just got sick from me on
the road and I had to take antibiotics
and then I had an allergic reaction to
them and wound up in the ER in Canada
when we never see people say I wound up
in the ER you drove yourself yeah just
where am I we're like no doctor was like
get to the ER like I called the
pharmacist like my legs are burning
could that be a reaction to cipro and
she was like yeah you know you should
get to the ER cuz they have to say that
or else they're gonna get sued I was
also in the woods looking for golf okay
I am I people did sauron hairspray on my
legs and my friend put a lighter on it
is that the same with that bro I've
never poison ivy isn't that weird you
haven't oh I've had poison ivy poison
oak sumac I've had all that shoe Mac
it's like never had it they're all
[ __ ] it's the same thing we should
take our hands we would get it as kids
we would it would it so bad we would
take our hands and our carpet we were
just rub them and it would feel so good
but in the morning when you woke up you
couldn't closer
we had to go get shots for it with it
was well you know they're like baking
soda somebody's well calamine lotion is
I'm lying but they also said bathe in um
how was it tomato oh yeah no that's gone
that's when you get uh it's bathing some
braids by a skunk ironically never got
poison oak wait you really did right Yes
No straight-up sprayed me okay it's
gonna be a new question we asked yet if
it's my risk of skunks straight-up
sprayed me cuz my on the course no he
was underneath the porch cuz we had a
black and white cat I when I was going
to need the port so I was like mini midi
mittens shortman and I just been like
high school at the time or middle school
like 12 and a skunk just came out and
sprayed me and my moms like we get in
the tub of what tomato juice onion I
should strong up for like what you know
smell it in the air when you're driving
but right up in your face I didn't know
I was happening cuz it kind of sprayed
me from behind like I kind of barely
remember this you're like my cat loves
my kids give me it's weird he's in the
golden showers but I got but amen cement
is it tomato juice work I think so like
there's memories I have that I barely
remember there's I'm confusing that with
the time I got lice like you know I just
remember this Oh phew mommy's your life
easy where you're in the bathtub and
someone's putting something smelly on
your cuz wasn't tomato juice for lice
too no no no but I'm yeah your mom I
just done that kid leftover tomato juice
they want to waste any of it like just
bust tomato juice admit they should tell
her she got lice yep total bloody mary
don't you that's what went in the Cape
Cod and that is ya dumb bad I put her in
there tart you got boys yeah there Ford
keep Connors on my head unbelievable I
mean I knew one person that got their
dog got sprayed by skunk oh yeah how
much tomato juice you need you get more
than one and first al it your parents
has had tomato juice on hand well i'm
sure we got a bit off club at the bar we
got it at the bar oh yeah it was like
having a second mr. Clamato give me
something baby girl got spray buzz ah i
want to say my mom washed my hair in
tomato juice I think that's what it was
she was not my body about my hair and
digesting I Dana
girl in college and they all is like
four girls lived in a house together and
a skunk went under their house and died
in this saw so they woke up their whole
house smelled like it they smelled like
it and they would each one to class and
people were like hey man watch that
[ __ ] that's I'd be so paranoid well get
a feminine wash girl to be paranoid if
your foot tell you that you should
definitely be if I had a swim like let's
say a stump which I was one of those
girls I wouldn't go to class singing
well at the very least they smell it
they'll know what it is I would assume
any time anyone smells anything bad they
say it's the lady's vagina near nearby I
mean the nearest a giant safe assumption
but yeah man that's I was making out I
smell that I'm not my [ __ ] just an FYI
everybody cuz I should open airplane
bathroom like this I'll know whatever
dev is the person before me that it's
not my post on 911 when the whole city
smelled like death I was running around
going not my post I'm kidding but I was
I can make that joke I was airman Daniel
yeah I smelled it I smelled the duck but
uh no but that's what happened with what
this you didn't date one of these no
hook up with some in her smelled like I
so know I've been dating her I knew her
and unfortunately for them a skunk just
climbed under there dumper after that no
no I didn't even see her that that week
they all had say but it said they said
it took like to be two or three baths of
tomato juice like that one did they
really do it for the house they had to
have one of those like forest fire
helicopter drops job tomato juice right
over the house Campbell sponsored it is
Kim or something like cauldron after
cauldron that was hot now it's hot soup
the drop open I've never enjoyed a
Bloody Mary I don't like the taste I
used to him but you don't want a rim on
you know obey room on it I don't like
obey that much I do you bought vodka and
I think cuz I don't drink vodka makes me
sick vodka mixed signal so what would
you use tequila get a bloody Maria
what's that I never heard of is that
real just make that that's real maybe I
would like that a Bloody Mary but with
tequila is a bloody maria is Mexican be
dis just this way it is cuz Maria is
kind of a Mexican name
yeah or Latin yeah whatever Spanish
Italian bunch of the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're
right it's everything I'm trying to
figure out what's the mean it up but
they sought a bloody Maria oh I should
try it I just I don't think I like
tomato juice but I see it on planes all
the time everybody's drinking it and
they say you crave that [ __ ] when you're
on a plane ginger ale is the one that
I'll drink on a plane that I don't ever
drink in like my day-to-day activity is
that same thing yeah why but nothing
from the producer Aaron yeah why cuz I
like the bubbles and it feels like an
hydrating but it's a little treat and it
Ward's off nausea I feel like hey if we
hit some turbulence I'm going to danger
yeah I go here love ginger ale and it
all that reminds me was my Nana she
always had ginger ale Oh kind Canada Dry
tiger Schweppes sometimes reps today's
don't make sure you but uh the only
other place for some reason yeah when we
use that they built the Kelly's roast
beef on route 1 and saugus you know
Kelly's umrah via that roast beef joint
I don't know but I know route 1 like a
[ __ ] okay dog everyone it's in
saugus rue one they put into Kelly's
member and good will hunting when
they're at the thing let's go to Kelly's
they go two counts but Kelly's must be
my mother grew up in Revere so we used
to go to Kelly's roast beef and then
they open the one in saugus so we would
just go to that one and every time we go
my buddy ride like getting a ga and I'm
like what he was getting a ga bro so we
always get a ginger ale oh so now like
what the so then we just started doing
it because every time we go like oh I
guess we're getting GA and that's what
we did I want to call it GA from now on
don't so it's tough i'm gonna go to Dan
Tana's and go give me a ga and just [ __ ]
with that guy even more yeah you know
you can do it Dan Tana's at a lot of
people don't know that I did one time as
a very sweet romantic valentine
Valentine's dinner is I ordered Dan
Tana's and I picked it up to go and
brought it home and then we ate Dan
Tana's at home instead of having to sit
there and go through the that's like
nice it's like 14 tables in there you
know what I mean right Chinese yam on
Valentine's Day you don't want to be out
with all these other money
no get you what a sweetie you are you
get some stick candles I got I got a lot
of stick candles yes let the place up
let the place on fire oh my god you're
such a sweetheart it really has a good
guy you're sort of your ok let me just
tell you something it's not romantic do
you think i don't know i don't think
it's a complete different way no it is a
competition and there is only one way
all right I think it's sickly I'd say
sophomore in high school from my high
school girlfriend for valentines day I
cooked her chicken piccata I made
chicken piccata over spaghetti with
three raviolis with a stripper red sauce
across each one and then I had garlic
bread and guess what else what we drink
I had a water glass wait I want to guess
and I had another I had wine glass but
what I put in the wine oh let me guess
something guess I know it I'm going
after you it's not ginger ale nope [ __ ]
wait because you weren't old enough to
drink right think of the time now can I
go can I write mine down sure no just
guess no cuz what if he then he stole my
guess Gary 7up no oh figured it looks
like rain before you look like wine
grape soda no Snapple snap laughing boom
oh snapple that doesn't look like wine
it wasn't supposed to look like wine on
said I'm trying to look like I said
cherry 7up cuz it would look like yeah
that's why he's my romantic Sickler wins
fine it's totally fine by me I only make
Jerry mom I met someone he put grape
soda in a glass good not like that other
loser who put Snapple in a wine glass it
doesn't he look like arable it looked
like brown wine we're serving brown wine
tonight it's organic and it's brown
because we let the grapes die and that's
really good for your immune system is
grape SAT fall off them cuz they decided
to die well oh we're there we're here
we're at that have anything else on
there um no we covered it we covered
everything jen kirkman touch you wanted
I got I got out what I came here to talk
including female
which is the leather doesn't subrata I
wanted to set the record [ __ ]
straight on that leather jacket [ __ ]
well thank you so much for being always
wall I love you know we love you too and
will you please one more time just plug
your social media all that stuff guys
catch me on a new show called don't
start laughing now on the CW hold on hey
great title don't start laughing yeah
it's like someone gets picked on their
whole life and then finally they're
accepted and they don't know how to
handle it that's a great time that's
good Jen Kirkman not comment from there
you'll find my podcast my Twitter my
Instagram also my name you can seem
personal things in funny things I see
all of it I see it all great to have you
on les always lower than noon when does
this come out Tuesday ah are you got any
more in them in the bank they're gonna
come yeah well tell you it's come yeah
oh you can't tell me on here on an Mafia
tell me um hey mr. coincide with some
promo I'm doing for uh for Schweppes at
least until I CW CW sniffer of it a
junket as always Jay Larson comic com
Jay Larson comedy on Facebook Twitter
Instagram and Pinterest Ryan Sickler on
Twitter Instagram Facebook Ryan Sickler
com we'll talk to y'all next Tuesday